welcome to the special report homepage  I'm Bret Baier we had a good discussion  on the panel tonight about trying to  keep the Russians out of the US  elections and some breaking news about  the FBI director and the Attorney  General and his deputy as well failing  to keep President Trump from  congratulating Vladimir Putin we talked  about that too  you can see the segment right here on  the website along with reports by  Catherine Herridge and John Roberts also  on the home page William la jeunesse  with the first comments from Facebook  CEO Mark Zuckerberg about the use of  customer information by a political  consulting firm Thursday I'll take you  on a tour of NIH the National Institutes  of Health and talk with the HHS  Secretary Alex azar will see at 6:00  p.m. Eastern on Fox News Channel four  special report